a recent CNBC interview with a
billionaire has gone viral after the
billionaire effectively said who cares
if some billionaires lose money because
of coronavirus there's an interesting
billionaire a guy I've been following
for a while his name is Chamath Polya
Padilla and he's believed to be just
barely a billionaire what I mean by that
is he was worth about 1.1 billion before
the coronavirus Fiasco maybe he's not a
billionaire today who knows he's roughly
a billionaire and what's interesting
about Chamath is that he's a venture
capitalist he was an early Facebook
executive but he seems to have more of
an understanding maybe because he grew
up in a family that depended on welfare
benefits he seems to better understand
that an economy really is about the
majority not about the billionaires and
I've been seeing more and more
interesting interviews with Chema on
CNBC and elsewhere he recently did a
great interview with Anthony Pompey on
oh one of our friends who has a YouTube
channel that you can check out but a few
days ago he was interviewed by CNBC
Scott Wapner about the economy in the
context of the coronavirus and Scott
Wapner started to wax poetic about Oh
what if billionaires lose money and
Chamath said quite simply who cares and
the who cares was so simple that it
visibly confused Scott Wapner so I'll
set it up for you this all started
because Chamath Polya padilla started to
explain what we should not do as we look
at bailing out companies during
coronavirus and what he said we
shouldn't do is we shouldn't prop up
zombie companies merely to save the
employees that you often hear we've got
to bail this company out because the
employees think of the employees and
Chamath explains why this is a false
notion check it out but are you suggest
you keep saying propping up zombie
companies or are you are you arguing to
let Airlines for example fail yeah why I
mean how does that make sense in the
broader scheme of the economy because
it's not because when you look at what
it means this is why I'm saying like
this is a lie that's been purported
by Wall Street when a company fails it
does not fire their employees it goes
through a package bankruptcy right if
anything what happens is the people who
have the pensions inside those companies
the employees of these companies end up
owning more of the company the people
that get wiped out are the speculators
that own the unsecured tranches of debt
for the folks that owned the equity and
by the way those are the rules of the
game that's right because these are the
people that purport to be the most
sophisticated investors in the world
they deserve to get wiped out but the
employees don't get wiped out so this is
a really important point just to start
with very often the justification for
bailing out a company is you've got to
save the employees now there are good
and bad reasons to bail out a company
but Chamath points out for these huge
companies like Airlines they don't just
go bankrupt lay everybody off say
bye-bye sell their airplanes for peanuts
and you never hear from them again
bankruptcy for these huge companies is a
process that includes restructuring it
often includes golden parachutes or big
payouts for the executives but it
includes all sorts of mechanisms for
reorganizing and very often not always
these bankruptcies work out okay for the
employees not all of them in every case
but in many cases and Shema this'
explaining that so now Scott Wapner
starts to wonder where Chamath is going
with this and it gets even better take a
look why does anybody do that understand
why does anybody deserve using your word
to get wiped out from a crisis created
like like this how does anybody is there
to get wiped out well good but just be
clear like who are we talking about
we're talking about a hedge fund that
serves a bunch of billionaire family
offices who cares let them get wiped out
who cares they don't get the summer in
the Hamptons who cares I mean they're
not you don't think the employees of
these companies owned stocks
I mean owned their stocks owned the
company stocks you can you can look on
Bloomberg and you can see what
percentage of these companies are
typically owned by these be things are
owned by black rocks these things
they're owned by these huge you know
Amorphis organizations ultimately
downstream and the employee owns a few
hundred dollars or a few
thousand dollars of wives donors this is
a key moment the employees don't deserve
to get wiped out they're not engaging in
speculative activity of little benefit
to the economy they are just working
their jobs the billionaires and the
hedge funds and the speculators they
also don't deserve to get what wiped out
but this is risk reward the billionaires
and the hedge funds and the speculators
they are choosing to take a risk for a
possibly huge reward
you can't just bail them out of that
risk this is the risk they decided to
take on the risk and reward need to be
in concert they are risking getting
wiped out to possibly get the huge
reward of making crazy money they then
get to another ruse which is this idea
of hey but the employees are
shareholders if the share price collapse
that hurts the employees I've said this
before the stock market is not an
indicator of the health of the economy
it is true many companies have employees
stock purchase programs employees own
stock in their company to some degree
but as trim off
out it is disproportionately tiny
amounts of stock the stock is mostly
held by executives by investment firms
like Blackrock and others outside of the
company it is another ruse that is used
to justify bailing out every company
without actually thinking critically
about whether they should be bailed out
let's now check out just the last
portion like a natural disaster why does
anybody deserve to get wiped out
wouldn't that be immoral in and of
itself no because what's happening right
now is what I'll tell you is on Main
Street today people are getting wiped
out and right now rich CEOs are not
boards that had horrible governance are
not hedge funds are not people are six
million people just this week alone
basically saying holy mackerel I don't
know how I'm gonna make you know my own
expenses for the next few weeks days
months so it's happening today to
individual Americans and what we've done
is disproportionately prop up and
protect you know poor performing CEOs
companies and boards and you have to
watch these people out let me introduce
an idea here it's sort of a combination
of an evolutionary idea and an economic
idea the coronavirus is terrible it's a
pandemic it's a crisis there's endless
suffering death and destruction as a
result in a way it can also serve as a
sort of filter for example there's the
idea that our behavior on earth is so
damaging to the planet and then you look
at the pandemic air travels down 95%
global carbon emissions are down air is
clearing water is clearing pollution is
declining it's going above and beyond
our normal actions and something is
saying nope we're gonna reverse the
trend briefly and work as a sort of
filter when it comes to economics there
is a ton of non-productive speculative
vulture activity that is not
economically productive we talk about an
economic multiplier that's the factor by
which one type of economic activity
multiplies through the economy so you
build a factory or you finance some
mortgages these actions have different
multipliers a ton of the stuff that's
being propped up with these bailouts is
very low multiplier action speculation
derivative trading leverage stuff it
generates profit for the people doing it
but it is a very little economic value
maybe this crisis is an opportunity to
filter out some of that nonsense that
helps hedge funds make a ton of money
but is not particularly good for the
economy really interesting stuff check
out other interviews with trimethyl
Padilla that he's done recently very
interesting billionaire we'll take a
quick break and we have so much more
coming up there's a YouTube channel
we're partnering with that I would love
for you to check out it's a channel
called up flip you can get there by
clicking the link below make sure you
subscribe when you're there every week
up flip uploads a new video where you
get an exclusive behind-the-scenes look
at a different small business everything
from real estate firms coffee shops auto
repair shops each business owner shares
a ton of really interesting insight
about how they built their business what
it's like day-to-day how they got to
where they are fascinating to learn
about other people's business strategies
how they found success it's a great
channel for anyone thinking of starting
a business already
running one or just people interested in
how different business work perfect for
people who like TV shows like Shark Tank
and that type of thing check it out at
david pakman.com slash up flip the link
is underneath the video they are friends
of the david pakman show make sure to
subscribe when you're there click that
Bell icon to be notified when they
upload new videos